it was an interesting experience for me
i was very nervous about the whole thing
real explosions rigging galore cars
being launched through the air just
another day on set for the spider-man no
way home team cgi played a vital role
and it was used way more often
throughout the movie than you'd expect
let's break it down you're holding
something in your hand that's just like
a green thing and they'll make it
something else later
number one
who was really in control
honestly in most of these high-risk
moments it's the stunt coordinators and
rigging teams who control the actors
movements and safety using harnesses
these compromising and dangerous
situations are made possible thanks to
the fact that cgi can disguise it all in
post
number two not everyone has to be on set
at once
coordinating all the actors in a marvel
film is tricky so in cases like this one
tony revolori filmed his portion with
nothing but a blue screen behind him
because of a scheduling conflict it
might not look advanced but the level of
detail needed to make the images flow
together seamlessly here is intense
number three goblin got a glider upgrade
returning to the screen 20 years later
meant willem dafoe got a major upgrade
with multiple different rigs to choose
from from scene to scene the actor was
rigged up to gliders attached to arms or
a mechanized glider that could move more
on its own leaving the finishing touches
up to the vfx team
it felt like something new it's like
being a circus performer number four
they got pretty up close and personal
not with the real statue of liberty but
the practical set they built worked in a
pinch while cgi brought the scene from
the iconic three spideys entering the
scene together to their working with
each other to take down the villains to
dr strange floating into the scene
harnesses special ringing and blue
screens in conjunction with the
brilliance of cg made this action
sequence on the statue of liberty very
memorable
that was great man it was so great
number five you've never seen electro
looking like this
jamie foxx got a major upgrade going
from full cg body to only partial cg
body fox was really floating with the
help of a special circular rig he was
secured to or depending on the action
rigged up to a giant mechanical arm
moving him through space crew members in
all blue were key in making the shot
smooth when he needed to whiz through
the air in studio a full pulley system
came into play
number six launch some cars crush some
concrete no big deal while cg took care
of the details and many of the larger
than life moments the team got to have
some fun with giant stunts and practical
effects like that time they literally
had a car launched a hundred and fifty
yards through the air only to crash and
damage other cars with water barrels
exploding bringing the stunt to the next
level while they were at it they got
their hands on some big concrete pipes
to launch into the ground with the
pulley system and throw some into some
other pipes
need a web to whip off a car door no
problem this stunt team will rig a
system to make it happen the adrenaline
this day on set was high
number seven anyone who could be wanted
to be on set for this action when it
came to capturing shots like this
everything had to be perfect since the
cost and work it takes to prep is
seriously major explosion day on set is
like the 4th of july with anyone who's
part of the film rushing to get to set
to witness the next level pyrotechnics
to make sure they took advantage of the
action a handful of cameras called crash
cams were in place close up to capture
the brutal explosion while keeping the
filmmakers safe
cg only enhanced but the team made a
reality
number eight they are here to fight
peter and goblin's final battle saw the
two in the most precarious of places
battling it out with hand-to-hand combat
that these actors actually did
themselves a partially built practical
set was built so willem and tom had a
sense of where they were cg managed to
bring the environment to life as well as
to hide all the safety measures in place
for the actors like harnesses that
allowed them to fight full out it was
the most incredible experience of my
career number nine
there were a thousand different versions
for just one moment when the claw was
coming down the no way home team wanted
to make sure they did it right cg was
the name of the game when we first meet
doc ock from d-aging alfred molina in
every single shot to every one of his
tentacles molina spent about 90 of his
time on set in a harness meanwhile
another percentage of his time was spent
standing on a platform and since that
body language didn't make sense for what
was being portrayed molina's body was
usually fully digitally replaced from
the neck down highly detailed
pre-visuals were vital to make before
filming what would end up being tom
running around in a mocap suit
performing all his stunts while molina
let his cg arms do all the heavy lifting
making small efforts where he needed to
for the camera we always needed to keep
realism and weight and speed and you
know action going number ten it's iconic
for a reason watching spider-man soar
through the sky like a flying squirrel
only to land perfectly is thanks to a
ton of work from the special effects
team tom did the stunts himself with the
help of a harness and practically built
sets but all the original footage would
end up being replaced through a process
that involved mocking up the full images
of every frame of what tom was doing
digitally whenever the iron spider-man
suit was meant to be used the team had a
physical bust made out of metal that
would be brought onto the camera to see
how the light would react with it so
they could bring the most authentic
visuals possible to the cg suit
number 11.
they seriously made it rain
seriously cg played a big part in the
background in establishing the weather
but one thing it did not do was create
all that rain the special effects team
made it poor rain in the studio so
holland could really feel the vibe of
this heartbreaking scene talk about
pathetic fallacy not a dry eye or tom in
the house
number 12. the building itself was
looking pretty rough green goblin and
peter really did a number on their
surroundings and each other with
hand-to-hand combat the two actors did
themselves in studio letting cgi compose
the rest of the settings so they could
keep the action high the team was able
to safely pull off moments that saw
actors going straight out of windows
with the help of harnesses that were
erased in post we'd never have guessed
this intense moment wasn't totally
authentic but the set they built for the
actors really was a perfect base for the
editing team to then create one of the
most realistic and dramatic looking
shots
it was fun it was a lot of fun and the
stunts is something i've always really
enjoyed number 13
every detail counts
cars on the road signs
the cg is subtle but key for nailing all
the details digital cars filled in
spaces needed in the aerial shots while
signs were actually modified to say
different things in this case making
sure the sign said airport since it was
an important part of the plot this kind
of thought is part of what makes this
movie so special when peter gets to jump
on the car just a little bit of cg was
used to hide the wires until a whole lot
of cg came into play to conceal him in
the iron spider suit
number 14 zendaya's brave face was
working hard to pull off these stunts
from freaking out on top of a bridge
which fortunately wasn't so terrifying
for the actress cg taking care of the
terrifyingly high backdrop two swinging
through the studio with a harness yes
but mainly trusting tom to be in control
well that took some guts the special
effects team reflected all the terror of
really doing the stunts and more
bringing the appropriate settings to the
screen while disguising the safety rigs
for the actors
and we did it and it was amazing and i'm
proud of myself for doing it you dropped
100 feet we did it
number 15.
settings aren't always what they seem to
be much of the time the team wasn't
necessarily on location but they
constructed a makeshift version to work
with like the steps and door frame built
in studio only to be completed in post
by what's called set extension in a
sense it's easier to create the world
rather than shoot it in new york every
detail from the way the light hits
floating leaves to some of the people in
the background are courtesy of our pal
cgi
without cg many of these scenes wouldn't
have been possible in fact only about 80
shots in the entire movie didn't use vfx
in some way what cgi detail were you
most surprised by